bonsoir alors si j'ai bien compris je
m'arrête du jeu c'est que je commence
par faire un petit panorama
je souhaite j'ai pris l'option ce soir
parce qu'il ya deux options une qui est
de faire un grand exposé avec support et
ce soir j'ai pris une option loria plein
youtube des conférences comme ça donc
pour ceux d'entre vous qui n'ont jamais
vu une conférence avec support vous
allez sur la chaîne youtube qui porte
mon nom et vous en avez jusqu'à la
nausée je vais vous dire pourquoi j'ai
décidé ce soir de faire quelque chose
qui était plus interactif qui sera
nécessairement plus court au niveau de
la de l'introduction sur l'exposé
liminaire
alors je vais quand même rappeler
quelques grandes données de cadrage qui
sont j'ai envie de dire éternel dans ce
genre de débat la première des données
que j'ai envie de rappeler c'est que
tous les débats sur l'énergie
aujourd'hui souffre d'un souffrent
généralement ça commence à être un peu
moins et souffre généralement à travers
qui est de voir l'énergie comme un sujet
sectorielle et technique
dit autrement qu'on peut déléguer à une
bande d'ingénieur en leur disant la
population souhaite que y ait un peu
plus de ceci un peu moins de ceux-là
dépatouiller vous pour que ça soit le
cas est absolument pas comme un sujet
transversal et systémique ce que
pourtant l'énergie est puisque en gros
augmenter la quantité d'énergie dont
dispose l'humanité c'est augmenter le
parc de machines dont dispose l'humanité
en fait l'énergie sert à mettre des
machines en mouvement et augmenter le
parc dont dispose l'humanité c'est
augmenter sa capacité de transformation
de l'environnement est tout ce qui va
avec
donc ce qui augmente avec notre capacité
de prendre transformation de
l'environnement c'est ce qu'on appelle
la production la production des biens et
services n'est rien d'autre que de
prendre des ressources et de les
transformer donc les vêtements que porte
en ce moment les gens qui regardent
cette conférence sur ce qu'ils sont tous
les deux parce que c'est surchauffée et
qui sont tout seuls et bien ont été
fabriqués par des machines à partir de
ressources naturelles la nourriture que
vous avez mangé avant que vous mangez
après cette conférence a été cultivé et
semer récolter transformer transportés
par des machines réfrigéré suite
tous les objets qu'ils sont chez vous de
votre brosse à dents au pot qui permet
aux fleurs de ne pas mettre de l'eau
partout quand on les arrose etc tout ça
ça a été fait par des machines
les étagères la fois regarder autour de
groupes je reste à votre logement a
aussi été fait par une machine
le plus souvent donc enfin vous par des
machines plus exactement six cimenteries
des aciéries des camions donc nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans un monde de
machines et l'énergie c'est la
nourriture de ces machines c'est ce qui
permet de les mettre en mouvement
en fait augmenter la quantité d'énergie
ou baisser la quantité d'énergie qu'on
utilise ou disserter sur la quantité et
la nature d'énergie qu'on utilise c'est
pas juste un débat technique on peut
déléguer à des ingénieurs
c'est en fait ce qui fait la puissance
des nations pendant un moment la france
puisque nous sommes dans une conférence
organisée par une école qui fait de
l'économie pendant un moment la france a
eu une production économique supérieure
à celle de la chine dans les années 50
pourtant à aucun moment jamais dans
l'histoire la france a eu une population
supérieure à celle de la chine
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on avait une
production supérieure tout simplement
parce qu'à cette époque-là on consommer
plus d'énergie c'est-à-dire qu'on avait
plus de machines en mouvement que la
chine est donc on pouvait faire plus de
tables de chaises de t-shirts et de
brosses à dents que les chinois et donc
nous avions un pib qui était supérieure
au pib étant la contrepartie économique
de notre production de biens et de
services ou la comptabilisation
économique de cette production donc
l'énergie
c'est d'abord la quantité de choses
qu'on produit comme c'est également les
machines qui comme pas renoncer les
machines qui travaillent aujourd'hui les
machines peuvent beaucoup travaillé avec
pas beaucoup d'hommes derrière
aujourd'hui dans toutes les usines on a
très peu de gens qui font travailler
beaucoup de machines ou un gros parc de
machines donc quand l'énergie arrive
quelque part et qu'on met les machines
au travail ont des formes totalement la
structure de l'emploi
en fait on a besoin de beaucoup moins de
gens dans les chambres ce que c'est les
tracteurs et les moissonneuses batteuses
qui cultive à notre place et les usines
d'engrais qui fertilisent à la place des
animaux de trait
on a besoin de beaucoup moins de gens
dans l'industrie on a beaucoup moins de
gens dans l'industrie automobile
aujourd'hui qui pourtant produit
beaucoup plus de voitures que ya cinq
ans parce que c'est les robots qui
produisent les voitures et les machines
et donc quand l'énergie arrive quelque
part ça déforme de manière massive la
structure de l'emploi et ça permet de
développer ce qu'on appelle les services
c'est à dire que en gros les machines
produisent beaucoup beaucoup et on a
derrière des services qui sont qui
correspondent à l'administration au sens
large de cette production d'eau par
exemple sa vente par exemple son
transport donc par exemple le fait de
vanter les mérites de ce qu'on a produit
et publicité donc par exemple
l'enseignement etc
à l'époque où la france était totalement
agricole et bien les enfants n'allaient
pas à l'école jules-ferry n'était pas
encore passée par là et les gens
n'avaient pas d'enseignement ou très peu
il était occupé à ramasser des patates
du début à la fin il n'y avait pas plus
d'instituteurs à tous les étages
il y en avait très peu donc en fait
contrairement à une idée couramment
répandue en particulier dans le monde
des économistes les emplois de service
c'est pas une dématérialisation de
l'économie c'est quelque chose qui
arrive au moment où l'économie est très
matériel parce qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup
de produits et à ce moment on a besoin
de beaucoup de monde pour les gérer par
ailleurs quand on a énormément d'énergie
on vide les campagnes parce que c'est
les machines qui se mettent à cultiver à
notre place du coup on peut rassembler
les gens d'abord dans des usines et
ensuite dans des bureaux et donc ont
fait grossir les villes donc les nerfs
de l'abondance énergétique
c'est également quelque chose qui
modifie de manière extrêmement
structurantes l'aménagement du
territoire tous les pays qui se sont mis
à disposer d'un abonnement
approvisionnements énergétiques
importants se sont tous urbanisées et
inversement vous ne savez pas faire
vivre une ville sans énergie abondante
parce que tous les gens qui vivent en
ville ont besoin d'y importer leur
nourriture et la nourriture
elle n'est plus cultivé parole
puisqu'ils sont vides et en vidant même
si on met quelques plants de tomates sur
les toits maintenant mais c'est quand
même pas les ordres des vendeurs de
vendeurs
donc on importe la nourriture on importe
les vêtements on importe tous les objets
que l'on utilise
et rien de tout ça les fabriquer sur
place donc en fait une vive est très
dépendante de flux de transport
elle est très dépendante de flux de
production de nourriture et de serre
d'objets qui prennent place à
l'extérieur donc en fait la ville à
grosse ville est la marque d'une société
énergivore
vous comprenez bien que si on doit
baisser l'approvisionnement énergétique
dans un pays par exemple parce que c'est
pas bon pour le climat ou si on doit le
baisser parce que l'on n'a plus assez de
pétrole de gaz et de charbon un portable
et bien à ce moment on a un problème
avec la taille des villes
c'est à dire que les villes deviennent
trop grosse pour que le pays puisse
continuer à fonctionner sans heurts j'y
reviendrai peut-être au moment des
questions le l'approvisionnement
énergétique en fait augmenté ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler la productivité du
travail
on n'est pas devenu très productif parce
que nous aurions tous la kul des bras et
des jambes supplémentaires qui vous
aurait poussé sur les épaules on se
mettrait avoir 15 bras d'un côté 25 de
l'autre intervenant en fait on est plus
productif tout simplement parce qu'on
commande des machines c'est simple
augmentation de la productivité du
travail c'est le fait de et du reste les
économistes le savent bien dans les
services la productivité augmente peu
dans les services on peut moins
facilement cédé machines et à ce
moment-là productivité beaucoup plus
difficile à faire augmenter donc cet
approvisionnement énergétique
en fait il a augmenté parce que ça a
permis d'augmenter la quantité de
production en mettant tout un tas de la
chine au travail et ça a permis de moins
se fatiguer nous est de ne plus faire la
même chose de notre temps ça nous a
libérés peu de temps libre pour faire
des études longues pour partir en
retraite pour avoir la semaine de 35
heures
un peu moins chez les cadres supérieurs
mais quand même pour avoir les week-ends
pour l'heure six semaines de congés
payés
donc en fait tout ça c'est le fruit de
l'énergie est très très marginalement la
qualité revendicatrice de la cgt ou du
medef alors cette énergie à un petit est
là elle a permis également pardon
l'accroissement démographique
puisqu'elle a permis la cantine
l'augmentation de la productivité
agricole la productivité céréalière en
france pour vous donner une idée elle
était en 1945 entre une et deux tonnes
de blé à l'hectare
donc 10 à 20 quintaux et aujourd'hui
elle est comprise entre 70 et 100 entre
60 et 100
mais en fait elle est entre 60 et 100
quasiment depuis 75 ans fait en trente
ans grâce aux tracteurs et aux engrais
les anglais étant fabriqués à partir de
gaz naturel
eh bien on a multiplié la productivité
agricole la productivité céréalière plus
exactement par 5 à 7
donc ça c'est l'énergie alors évidemment
quand vous multipliez la productivité à
l'hectare par 5 à 7 vous pouvez nourrir
plus de monde donc l'abondance
énergétique a aussi permis à la
démographie d'augmenter à plusieurs
titres d'abord parce que ça permet de
nourrir les gens où qu'ils soient
alors qu'avant les gens ne pouvaient
être nourris que là où ça poussait
ensuite ça permet d'augmenter la
prophylaxie
par exemple vous amener de l'eau qui est
potable et vous évacuer les crottes et
autres trucs qui sont pas terribles et
les cadavres qui sont pas terribles pour
vivre sans miasmes donc en fait
l'approvisionnement énergétique a
augmenté la quantité de nourriture la
sécurité alimentaire et la prophylaxie
et ça ça a permis à la population de
l'augmenter de manière très fortement
sur terre en fait l'explosion
démographique est concomitante de la
révolution industrielle donc l'énergie a
vraiment c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est très très structurant sur la
façon dont les choses se passent sur
terre ça n'est pas juste je le répète un
domaine technique que l'on peut
sous-traiter aux ingénieurs en leur
disant pour écouter actuellement le
nucléaire c'est kaka fait moi des
éoliennes le pétrole c'est pas terrible
à fait moi encore plus d'éoliennes etc
et puis tout ira bien et que l'on vienne
pas liquidée par ailleurs avec c'est pas
votre problème vous les ingénieurs de
vous occuper des trucs sérieux les
retraites l'économie
est ce qu'on doit ou non accepter les
musulmans dans tout ça c'est pas votre
problème
occupez vous donc juste de faire de
l'énergie alors en fait non l'énergie
interfère avec tout ce que je viens
d'évoquer
et y compris les preuves de religion en
fait quand on regarde bien ce que les ce
que c'est que l'énergie ça interfère
avec absolument l'épreuve de religion
juste en passant le découpage actuel du
moyen-orient a été fait par les
puissances occidentales pour se partager
le pétrole à l'époque où il y avait
trois bidons à sur place sauf que grâce
au pétrole les trois bédouins sont
devenus beaucoup plus nombreux non ça
pose quelques problèmes
donc le l'énergie je le redis c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est
extrêmement structurants sur la façon
dont les choses se passent dans le monde
c'est pas un débat technique évidemment
des éléments techniques cette profusion
énergétique elle a eu un certain nombre
de conséquences directes ou indirectes
dans les conséquences directes
il y en a une très importante qui est ce
qu'on appelle maintenant le changement
climatique
alors qu'est ce que c'est que le
changement climatique c'est le fait que
l'homme est devenu un agent de forçage
du système climatique
le système climatique c'est le système
qui régit les conditions ambiantes de
température de pression de luminosité de
précipitations est partout sur terre
c'est une grosse machine thermodynamique
dans laquelle vous allez trouver l'océan
l'atmosphère les sols la végétation et
cette machine est alimenté comme toutes
les machines par de l'énergie solaire
par toutes les machines sont pas
alimentés par l'énergie solaire
iliad est alimenté par l'énergie des
machines et cette énergie solaire et ce
système climatique
il a toujours été ce qu'on appelle force
et c'est à dire qu'il ya des éléments de
perturbations extérieures ou internes au
système climatique qui viennent le
modifier dans le temps alors au cours de
la dernière des derniers millions
d'années
la perturbation le forçage qui a été le
plus important c'est celui qui a
provoqué le site que vous avez peut-être
appris à l'école entre les ères
glaciaires et les airs interglaciaire
les ères glaciaires était très très
froid et les mammouths qui se baladent
il ya des glaciers partout etc
heller interglaciaire c'est celle la
plus récente c'est celle qui a permis la
sédentarisation de notre espèce en
déglaçant les moyennes latitudes et
c'est à ce moment là que nous sommes
c'est en parisis alors l'ère glaciaire
et qui est l'air qui a pris place le
plus souvent sur terre sur les deux à
trois derniers millions d'années
heller interglaciaire leur alternance
est provoquée par le fait que dans le
système solaire nous sommes dans un
ménage à 9
on va dire
et que la terre ne subit pas juste la
traction du soleil mais elle subit
également la traction significative de
jupiter et saturne sur les très grosses
planètes et ça ça fait que l'orbité
terrestre n'est pas régulière au cours
du temps et c'est ça qui a engendré
donc c'est un élément de forçage qui a
engendré une variation naturelle du
système climatique dans les autres
éléments de forçage aller par exemple la
dérive des continents qui fait que comme
les continents sont pas au même endroit
tout le temps et bien ils peuvent
il peut y avoir de la neige ou pas de
neige ils peuvent réfléchir les rayons
du soleil ou pas les réfléchi et ça ça
change également le système climatique
terrestre est aujourd'hui l'activité
humaine est aussi un facteur de forçage
du système climatique c'est à dire que
ça change
à vitesse accélérée par rapport à ce qui
se passait avant les conditions
climatiques environnantes alors ça les a
déjà changé et surtout ça a pas beaucoup
les changer à l'avenir ce forçage
climatique
il vient de ce qu'on appelle les gaz à
effet de serre alors un gaz à effet de
serre en en physique ça une définition
très simple pas facile à comprendre mais
quand même très simple c'est un gaz qui
absorbe les infrarouges de grandes
longueurs d'onde émis par la surface de
la planète
vous savez que les corps peuvent émettre
des infrarouges par exemple mon corps
émet des infrarouges
donc si vous regardiez avec une caméra
infrarouge est de regarder aux yeux eh
bien vous verriez quand même ma tête
vous savez caméra infrarouge permettent
de voir ce qu'ils aiment et de la
chaleur mon corps et mes de la chaleur
mais il se trouve que le sol terrestre
émettent de la chaleur et même quand il
est à zéro degré comme en ce moment en
soi ou à 5 degrés comme en ce moment en
ile de france
ça a aimé quand même de la chaleur moins
que quand il est à 30 degrés mais ça en
est mais quand même alors cette chaleur
en fait elle correspond à du rayonnement
température permet au corps de rayonner
un rayonnement électromagnétique qui
appelle de l'infrarouge ans qui
ressemble beaucoup à la lumière visible
mais avec des longueurs d'onde un peu
plus grande et c'est infrarouge a la
particularité de pouvoir être absorbé
dans l'atmosphère par ce qu'on appelle
les gaz à effet de serre c'est
exactement à ça qu'ils servent
ils sont connus depuis un siècle et demi
l'effet de serre est connu depuis deux
siècles célébrer le bicentenaire dans
pas longtemps ça a été découvert par
joseph fourier en 1824 est donc cet
effet de serre correspond juste au fait
qu' il ya des gaz dans l'atmosphère qui
intercepte les infrarouges émis par la
surface de la planète
alors quand vous rajoutez des gaz comme
ça de cette nature dans l'atmosphère les
infrarouges sont interceptés de plus en
plus fortement près de la surface et
donc ça confine l'énergie près de la
surface et ça augmente la température
moyenne du sol
voilà c'est ça en gros l'effet de serre
tel qu'il se présente à nos yeux
alors la raison pour laquelle l'usagé de
l'énergie augmente l'effet de serre
c'est parce que l'essentiel de l'énergie
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelle des combustibles fossibles alors
ces combustibles sur les cerveaux le
donc je prends des corps et je les
associe avec de l'oxygène c'est ça la
combustion et ça me dégage de l'énergie
et fossiles tout simplement parce que
c'est les restes de vie ancienne le
pétrole et le gaz c'est des restes de
plancton alors la géothermie
j'en ai un peu mais les uns etc des
restes de plancton qui a vécu n'importe
quoi entre ya 50 et 400 millions
d'années et le charbon c'est les restes
de fougères qui ont poussé à l'ère du
charbon carbonifère il ya à peu près 300
millions d'années
donc c'est des faux cils et ça brûle
parce que c'est plein de carbone et
d'hydrogène
alors quand vous brûlez de l'hydrogène
ça fait de la vapeur d'eau la vapeur
d'eau est un gaz à effet de serre mais
enfin ce qui vient des activités
humaines est totalement négligeable
devient seul devant ce qui vient de la
nature puisque la nature
c'est une énorme machine à évaporer la
terre est couverte aux deux tiers
d'océan beaucoup beaucoup des
majorations
est ce que les hommes peuvent émettre
soit en brûlant du gaz avec de
l'hydrogène soit dans lequel il ya
d'hydrogène soit par exemple avec les
tours de réfrigération des centrales
électriques parc nucléaire des centrales
à charbon
tout ça c'est parfaitement négligeable
d'avant l'évaporation naturelle mais par
contre il ya un gaz pour lequel ce n'est
pas négligeable du tout c'est le gaz
carbonique
donc quand vous brûlez du un composé
d'un cahier du carbone d'oxydé de
carbone ça vous fait du dioxyde de
carbone c'est ça le gaz carbonique
et le gaz carbonique est aussi un gaz à
effet de serre et alors là par contre ce
que les hommes rajoute dans l'atmosphère
change la composition atmosphérique
parce que le gaz carbonique à une très
très vilaine caractéristiques
en tout cas elle est très vilaine en
l'espèce c'est que une fois qu'il est
dans l'air
le gaz carbonique il est inaltérable
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de
processus d'épuration il est éternel
tant qu'il est dans l'air pour que le
gaz carbonique veuille bien ressortir de
l'atmosphère
il faut qu'ils reviennent au contact du
sol d'autant qu'il est loin loin tu
arrives rien et quand il revient au
contact du sol
il peut soit être repris par la
végétation avec la photosynthèse soit
être dissous dans l'eau océanique où il
est transitoirement stocker on va dire
mais c'est pas un processus d'épuration
chimiques mais tant qu'il est au milieu
de la poster il y aurait alors comme il
lui arrive de rien tant qu'il est au
milieu de l'atmosphère il va avoir
tendance à s'accumuler dans l'atmosphère
en fait nous émissions de gaz à effet de
serre commencer par nos émissions de gaz
carbonique rajoute du co2 dans
l'atmosphère de manière cumulative
il ya d'autres gaz à effet de serre le
plus important auprès de gaz carbonique
s'appelle le méthane
il est émis par les ruminants savez que
dans les ruminants les ruminants
plusieurs estomacs sont supérieures de
vue notamment les vaches
vous avez un milliard et demi de vaches
sur terre le poids des vaches est à peu
près égal au poids des hommes sur terre
et les vaches roth du méthane à cause de
ce qui se passe dans leur estomac trois
ans et c'est qu'elles mangent de l'herbe
puis ça fermente là dedans et le méthane
ressort par le tube digestif
enfin vous parle les hauts faits
exactement alors le quai les vaches les
rizières
parce que le métal et le gaz de la
putréfaction et dans les rizières via
des petits débris organiques qui
pourrissent à l'abri de l'oxygène de
l'air vous avez du méthane dans
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures les
fuites de gaz la ventilation des mines
de charbon
voilà donc vous avez des émissions de
méthane et puis après vous avez encore
d'autres gaz à effet de serre mais qui
sont plus mineures on va dire dans le
processus global le protoxyde d'azoté
gaz halogénés d'état
le principal gaz à effet de serre c'est
donc le co2 le deuxième principal encore
très significatif
c'est le médecin alors le les émissions
augmenter et donc le climat a commencé à
se modifier
alors il a commencé seulement parce que
la très mauvaise nouvelle à cause du
caractère inaltérable du co2 temps qu'il
est dans l'air c'est qu' il faudra
attendre des milliers d'années je dis
bien des milliers d'années après arrêt
des émissions pour que le co2
supplémentaire que nous avons rajouté
dans leur finissent par ces curés en
fait il faudra attendre plus de dix
mille ans pour que après arrêt des
émissions et à supposer qu'on n'ait pas
changé les choses de manière
irréversible et bien le surplus de co2
que nous avons rajouté dans l'air est
fini de ces purées alors il faut que je
vous ai dit ça je vous ai dit quelque
chose de terrible c'est qu'il n'existe
pas de retour en arrière en ce qui
concerne le changement climatique c'est
à dire que la modification du climat
une fois qu'elle est là elle n'est pas
réversible donc le climat de l'an 2000
vous ne le reverrez jamais je ne le
reverrai jamais il est perdu à tout
jamais et même le climat de l'an 2020 à
se perdre à tout jamais parce que au
moment vous arrêtez les émissions vous
avez quand même
ou plus exactement au moment où vous
passez par le maximum des émissions
parce qu'il va pas s'arrêter en 24
heures
enfin les émissions on va s'arrêter à
20h sauf disparition instantanée de
l'humanité donc c'est parce qu'on est un
qu'ovide très très efficace et que
quelqu'un nous aurons plus de non plus
de problème de changement climatique
sont tous morts eh bien les émissions
vont pas s'arrêter en une nuit ce qui va
se passer c'est qu'elles vont passer par
un maximum puis derrière elles vont se
mettre à décliner et bien après passage
du maximum il faudra par exemple
attendre des milliers d'années pour que
l'océan s'arrête de monter des milliers
d'années pour que l'océan s'arrête
d'augmenter il faudra attendre des
décennies pour que le co2 s'arrête de
monter parce que tant pour ajouter du
co2 dans l'atmosphère ça va quand même
continuer à monter un peu il faudra
attendre des siècles avant que des
décennies et des siècles ça dépend avant
que la température se stabilise
donc vous voyez on a on a
sur des pas de temps qu'ils sont
extrêmement longs et par exemple il faut
savoir que la modification du climat que
nous allons vivre dans les 20 ans qui
viennent
eh bien elle est raisonnablement
indépendante de ce que nous allons faire
sur les émissions serre que même si
demain matin on se dit ou alors tout ça
sent mauvais on va commencer à appuyer
très fortement sur la [ __ ] de frein en
termes d'émissions je vous dirai après
ce que ça veut dire
et bien pour autant le changement
climatique des 20 prochaines années il
est déjà embarqué en quasi totalité dans
nos émissions passées de toute façon les
canicules vont augmenter de toute façon
mais sécheresse mois augmenté en france
de toute façon une partie croissante de
la forêt va mourir de toute façon une
partie des cours d'eau va être de plus
en plus en déficit
l'été etc tout ça est déjà inscrit
malheureusement dans les émissions
passées vous savez qu'en matière de
climat il ya un un accord qui a été
signé il ya maintenant 92 18 38 ans qui
est la convention cadre des nations
unies pour le changement climatique
donc il ya 38 ans tous les chefs d'état
à l'époque en france et évité rend son
ministre de l'environnement à l'époque
c'était brice lalonde se réunissent à
rio 1992 donnant deux pour le sommet de
la terre est au sommet de la terre on
signe qu'à plusieurs conventions dont la
convention climat qui est celle qui dit
qu' il faudrait faire quelque chose pour
que le changement climatique ne nous
enquiquine pas trop ça c'est la version
très français enfin en français bulgarie
zay la formulation onusienne s'est il
faut limiter le changement climatique
anthropique à un niveau qui ne présente
pas de danger pour l'homme
c'est ça qui est c'est ça qui est dit
alors cet objectif là il est déjà perdue
parce que le changement climatique a
déjà commencé à faire des choses qui
sont un peu dangereuse pour les hommes
par exemple un papier est paru très
récemment dans une revue scientifique
qui est la revue scientifique de
l'académie des sciences américaine
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences ceux des états unis et qui dit
que le changement climatique a très
vraisemblablement joué un rôle
déclencheur
dans le conflit syrien le conflit syrien
je vous rappelle qu'il a envoyé 1
millions réfugiés en europe d'envoyer le
changement climatique ça va pas se
limiter à ce que des présentateurs météo
vous dise
affolée une fois par mois ou là là il va
faire très chaud dans la ville vous
allez mal dormir non pas à un changement
climatique le changement climatique
c'est des déstabilisations à large
échelle des gens qui n'ont plus à manger
les gens qui vont se taper dessus des
gens qui vont migrer des écosystèmes qui
vont dépérir et in fine et le bazar
c'est un le changement climatique est
tout à l'heure on a cité le titre d'un
de mes livres
ça va être deux ans mais tranquille
jusqu'en 2100 bien évidemment c'est du
second degré ou du troisième puisque le
sous titre était et autre malentendu sur
le climat et l'énergie
bien évidemment que les emmerdements
vont pas attendre 2005 pour se
manifester alors quand j'ai écrit ce
livre les gens l'avaient pour n'avait
pas encore clairement conscience
maintenant on commence à voir il ya
l'équivalent d'un tiers de la superficie
française qui est parti en fumée en
australie essentiellement en vantant pas
essentiellement mais pour une bonne
partie dans des zones protégées dans des
parcs naturels etc
donc c'est la belle belle végétation
avec plein de biodiversité peur
d'américains à plein de la ligue au
pardon l'américain joli lapsus donc
plein un plat d'aligot les américains en
fait je voulais en parler parce que en
californie vous avez aussi d incendie
très important mais vous en avez aussi
au brésil dans le pantanal vous avez
enfin bref
donc ça commence à sentir le roussi au
sens premier du terme
vous en avez eu plein en sibérie
également parce qu'il ya eu des
anomalies de températures extrêmement
positive au printemps dernier mais
malheureusement quand ce genre de choses
commencent à arriver à cause de ce que
j'ai dit c'est trop tard pour revenir en
arrière
donc ça va s'amplifier ces choses là
donc si on veut à partir de maintenant
ne pas trop trop prendre de risques à
supposer que l'on puisse encore et que
on veut coller à ce qui est dit comme
étant l'objectif politique ce qui est
évoqué comme étant l'objectif politique
aujourd'hui de la limite des 2 degrés
alors est ce que 2 degrés c'est une
bonne limite scientifique va ça j'en
sais rien vous n'en savez rien personne
n'en sait rien
à deux degrés par exemple l'essentiel
des coraux sont déjà morts parce que
c'est sans risque que l'essentiel des
coraux soient déjà morts
tu pas sûr ça va peut-être déjà provoqué
un certain nombre de 1 peu de malheur de
désespoir et des conflits à droite et à
gauche à deux degrés vous avez les êtres
qui ont disparu de l'essentiel de la
super fier de la surface française
voilà ce que c'est grave parce que c'est
dangereux parce que c'est pas dangereux
pour le moment les urbains que nous
sommes ont un peu tendance à considérer
que tant que ça touche pas trop à notre
porte modèle que ça nous empêche pas de
regarder le foot à la télé c'est pas
très grave
sauf que quand on en sera là les choses
seront trop avancé pour ce soit
réversible donc à ce moment là on pourra
donc le si on veut éviter
on va dire ce qui est aujourd'hui
considéré comme le pire c'est-à-dire
au-delà de deux degrés alors là il ya la
physique vous dis c'est très simple vous
avez encore le droit de mettre dans
l'atmosphère le tiers de ce qu'on a déjà
émis jusqu'à maintenant c'est ça que
vous dites à physique donc le tiers de
ce qui a été émis entre l'ère
préindustrielle et 2020 et ça correspond
à des émissions planétaires qui baisse
de 5% par an tous les ans à partir de
maintenant alors une baisse de 5%
maintenant on a un petit aperçu de ce
que cède ses locaux vides
le coc vide engendre 5% de baisse des
émissions sur un non alors sur un an ce
n'est pas suffisant du tout c'est la
raison pour laquelle la concentration en
co2 à la fin de 2020 était supérieure à
celle à la fin 2019 et même avec des
émissions qui baissent de 10 c'est
encore le cas et même avec des émissions
qui baisse de 30 c'est encore le cas et
même avec des émissions qui baisse de
50% c'est encore le cas à cause de ce
caractère inaltérable du co2 une fois
dans l'atmosphère en fait pour que la
concentration atmosphérique s'arrête
d'augmenter il y avait des missions
deviennent nul zéro alors tant qu'on n'y
est pas et pour moment évidemment on n'y
est pas la concentration continue
d'augmenter et pour qu'elle s'arrête
d'augmenter il faut donc le plus vite
possible que les émissions deviennent
nul alors le plus vite possible
si on veut
limiter la hausse à 2 degrés c'est 2050
2060 2070 latence et zola et ça veut
dire des émissions qui baisse de 5% par
an dit autrement ça veut dire qu'à la
fin de l'année la 2020 on se dit oh là
là on repart pas du tout comme avant on
reste là où on l économie ont l'art
développe pas qu'ils allaient prochaine
on se reprend à 1 qu'ovide
supplémentaires prochaine trac on vous
en recause un coup ou que les émissions
baisser à nouveau de 5 %
c'est ça que ça veut dire vite et le
climat à 2 2 alors vous comprenez bien
là aussi que c'est pas un objectif que
vous pouvez mettre donc je n'ai dit tout
à l'heure pour l'énergie ont pas confier
sa bande d'ingénieur en leur disant dans
la drôme un coin aubin vous avez qu à
faire ce qu'il faut et puis moi n'est
pas mon kit il et je vais toujours
pouvoir vivre comme aujourd'hui le
climat c'est exactement pareil
vous ne pouvez pas demander à une bombe
de scientifiques et de chez toi qui es
de militants écolos devons régler le
problème pendant qu'ailleurs
rien ne change en fait les tenir la
limite des deux degrés s'est changée
tous partout tout le temps
c'est changer la façon dont on mange
s'échanger les distances qu'on est
capable de parcourir c'est baisser notre
pouvoir d'achat
c'est changer la façon dont on se loge
c'est tous à la limite des 2 2 alors
vous allez me dire ah ben c'est horrible
non sauf qu'on va prendre quand même
parce que entre le fait que les stocks
fossiles sont épuisables et le fait que
au delà d'un certain niveau de
réchauffement climatique
les sociétés seront en vente elle d'
état de désordre que de toute façon on
aura un effondrement économique va
malheureusement il n'y a pas le choix
donc la décroissance on va la supplier
pour vous la gérez mais malheureusement
l'éviter ça ne sera pas possible ça ne
sera pas possible parce que je le répète
c'est pas le progrès technique qui fait
la croissance économique
c'est le fait qu'on ait des ressources
naturelles à transformer notamment avec
des machines parce que sans ressources
naturelles vous n'avez pas de produits
et donc vous n'avez pas d'économie vous
vous rappelez peut-être pour certains
d'entre vous que la raison pour laquelle
les ressources naturelles ne valent rien
dans notre convention économique c'est
parce qu'on l'a postuler comme hypothèse
il ya deux siècles
il ya deux siècles on a dit mme campeau
fera de l'économie on considéra que les
ressources naturelles c'est gratuit
c'est explicitement marqué comme ça dans
le traité d'économie politique de jean
baptiste say qui a été écrit à deux
siècles
donc le sait pas parce qu'on ne compte
pas que ça n'a pas d'importance
j'ai juste décidé que c'était ça la
convention alors la conséquence c'est
que pour régler les problèmes
d'environnement les prix ne servent à
rien de dire ça voilà donc voila un
petit panorama de la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes
pour ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent
faust vous savez que le pacte faustien
ses impacts qui commence par une période
très très douce mais avec un tout petit
inconvénient c'est que l'on a vendu son
âme au diable
eh bien là c'est exactement la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes
nous avons vécu deux siècles de corne
d'abondance pour l'humanité mais avec un
tout petit inconvénient on sait qu'on
est en train de scier la branche sur
laquelle nous sommes assis et que la
hauteur de chute promet de ne pas être
complètement négligeable si on veut
maintenant faire face à cette situation
malheureusement il faut faire notre
deuil d'un certain nombre de choses il
faut faire notre deuil de l'idée que la
croissance est compatible avec la
solution aux problèmes environnementaux
malheureusement c'est pas vrai ou en
tout cas c'est pas vrai au sens matériel
alors après on peut dire que il ya une
croissance virtuel il faut faire notre
deuil de l'absence d'observation des
faits il ya un certain nombre de nos
jour d'hui nous vivons dans un monde
dans lequel on prend pour acquis des
slogans en pensant qu'ils sont égaux ou
fait par exemple le numérique c'est
dématérialisée alors ça c'est un slogan
en fait quand vous regardez les faits le
numérique c'est parfaitement matériel
l'ordinateur que je suis en train
d'utiliser en ce moment il a été fait
avec 40 métaux différents
il a bien fallu faire des trous dans la
terre sortir les métaux les raffiner
utiliser du pétrole pour faire
fonctionner toutes ces industries plus
faire des spécialités et qui se retrouve
dans mon ordinateur et s'est creusé des
trous dans la terre pour sortir du
charbon pour faire d'électricité en
chine à taiwan et en corée pour faire la
dalle d'écran mon ordinateur etc
donc tout ça est parfaitement matériel
et le signal est en train en ce moment
de vous parvenir via des réseaux
télécoms qui sont faits avec deux des
fibres optiques parfaitement matériel
des fils de cuivre parfaitement matériel
ça passe par des ordinateurs des
serveurs des routeurs
savait parfaitement matériel ça arrive
chez vous sur d'autres ordinateurs
parfaitement matériel aussi donc voilà
un exemple où on confond le slogan et
les faits le numérique c'est pas du tout
dématérialisé le digital c'est pas du
tout dématérialisé et du reste
l'industrie du numérique est une des
rares industries sur terre où le contenu
en carbone d'un euro de valeur ajoutée
augmentent année après année et
matérialise donc on va voir on va avoir
besoin également de faire notre deuil
d'un certain nombre de slogans
on pense être liée à la compenser go à
l'examen des faits ce com pareil les
avez les emplois tertiaires
c'est des emplois qui permettent de
débats d réaliser l'économie non pas du
tout c'est des emplois qui apparaissent
uniquement dans les économies ne va
avoir besoin de regarder les problèmes
en face on va avoir besoin de faire les
choses de manière un peu différente de
ce qu'on faisait de par le passé par
exemple la concurrence et les pays
ouvert à tous les vents ça ne permet pas
ça raccourci les horizons de temps et
donc ça ne permet pas de planifier la
sortie des énergies fossiles
donc l'idée que le libre échangisme peu
partout et tout le temps c'est
merveilleux ben non malheureusement il
va falloir enfin voilà donc il ya un
certain nombre de deux de ses frères en
versant ce problème là et vous voyez que
nous sommes très très loin d'un problème
d'ingénieurs qui peuvent être résolus
avec quelqu'un qui tombe des bons
boutons dans un coin voilà je vais
m'arrêter là et laisser la place aux
questions
en espérant qu'il y en a quelques-unes
merci beaucoup mais déjà beaucoup de
questions délicates elle valait pour
synthétiser et déposé moi j'ai dit d'une
manière générale c'est devant ce tableau
est finalement très réaliste entre le
résultat de tout ton analyse depuis des
années et de son professionnalisme
finalement c'est très inquiétant et
tresses qu'il ya des acteurs parmi tous
ceux qui peuvent faire quelque chose qui
sont les plus importants pour essayer
de limiter les conséquences malgré que
tu dises que pendant les 20 prochaines
années c'est déjà écrit on peut plus
faire grand chose mais est ce que c'est
les gouvernements est ce que ce sont les
organisations internationales
quels sont les industriels m2 le choix
entre les différentes technologies entre
nay l'éolien ou entre le m le
renouvelable
quels sont les acteurs qui devrait
essayer d'avoir qui comprennent d'abord
le problème soit c'est la première
question c'est bien comprendre le
problème est qu'elles sont ceux qui
peuvent avoir un impact plus important
que les autres doit couvrir tous ses
acteurs quels sont ceux qui apparaissent
comme étant porteurs finalement de
d'optimisme sur ce qu'on pourrait faire
en fait tout le monde dans cette affaire
a un rôle à jouer
c'est à dire que l'idée qu'on aurait un
acteur providentiel will catégories
d'acteurs providentiel est
malheureusement une idée à laquelle je
ne souscris pas tout le monde va devoir
faire sa part dans cette affaire là
alors si on regarde ce qui est j'ai
envie de dire de la responsabilité des
différentes catégories d'acteurs
effectivement ce qui est de la
responsabilité d'absolument tout le
monde et d'essayer de bien comprendre le
problème à traiter et cette
responsabilité est encore supérieure
quand les personnes concernées ont reçu
la charge de gérer quelque chose
donc j'ai envie de dire c'est
particulièrement coupable
quant à chefs d'entreprise ne
s'informent pas et ne fait pas ce qu'il
faut pour que son encadrement s'informe
c'est particulièrement coupable quand
des dirigeants politiques ne s'informent
pas et ne font pas ce qu'il faut pour
que leurs écosystèmes soient
correctement informés
c'est particulièrement coupable quand
des enseignants qui ont la charge de
préparer le monde de demain puisque
normalement on enseigne d information on
en sait des choses qui sont utiles pour
le monde de demain devrait pas pour le
monde d'hier
bon
sont un peu trop rétifs à l'idée de
faire de la place à ce sujet alors qu'il
est quand même quelque part plus
important que de savoir quelle était la
couleur du site de charlemagne
donc c'est particulière j'ai envie de
dire tout le monde doit et c'est
particulièrement coupable quant à presse
ne fait pas l'effort de vulgariser
correctement le problème maintenant
chacun il incombe à chacun de s'informer
vous avez nul n'est censé ignorer la loi
là j'ai envie de dire quand on a un
problème aussi important sur les bras
quelque part on pourrait dire la même
chose nul n'est censé ignorer la manière
dont se présente le problème c'est
d'autant plus coupable je le redis quand
on est déjà maître de son destin à court
terme et que on n'a pas l'angoissé des
fins de mois pour reprendre une
expression récente et une angoisse du
court terme qui vous empêche de penser à
quoi que ce soit d'autre
dans les temps anciens la science été
faite par les rentiers parce que c'était
les sols qui avait la liberté d'esprit
pour se consacrer aux choses de l'esprit
justement on ne connaît aucun
scientifique célèbre il ya trois ou
quatre siècles qui était paysan moi j'en
connais pas un seul ils étaient tous
rentiers puisque c'étaient les seuls qui
avaient du temps et bien j'ai envie de
dire maintenant les seuls qui sont à
l'abri du besoin à court terme ou ceux
qui sont à l'abri du besoin à court
terme je pense qu'ils ont un devoir de
s'informer sur ce genre de sujet qui est
particulièrement élevé et donc ça vaut
notamment puisque on est dans une
conférence organisée par l'insee a dit
ce que je dis s'applique en particulier
al ittihad
donc si l'insee à d'aujourd'hui ne dit
rien à ses élèves
et quand je dis rien il s'agit pas de
leur dire c'est important il s'agit de
leur faire dix heures de cours sur le
sujet eh ben c'est pas bien c'est mal
ici les gens qui sont passés par l'insee
had ne font pas l'effort de s'intéresser
à ce sujet
eh ben c'est pas bien c'est mal donc ça
c'est pour laisser pour les individus et
l'information
après
les entreprises ont le devoir de
préparer leur avenir face à ce qu'elles
ont le devoir non seulement de
s'informer mais elles ont le devoir de
comprendre ce que ça peut vouloir dire
pour leurs activités et de voir comment
est-ce qu'elles s'organisent au mieux
pour rendre cette activité compatible
avec la contrainte
au lieu d'essayer de résister à la
contrainte qu'elles font en général les
partis politiques doivent essayer
d'avoir des plans pour l'ensemble de la
société qui ne présuppose pas qu'il ya
un coup de baguette magique qui va
passer par là pour résoudre les
problèmes à leur place quand j'entends
monsieur le maire a expliqué qu'après le
coc vite c'est la croissance qui va
rembourser la dette
je me dis que cet homme était
inconscient ou un menteur mais c'est
l'un des deux il n'y a pas de troisième
possibilité enfin inconscient à nyon
menteur et c'est vrai également pour les
consommateurs que nous sommes
parce qu'il ya un moment aussi où
personne ne nous met un revolver sur la
tempe avant on achète les choses
alors tout ça est facile à dire plus ou
moins facile à faire en particulier il
ya quelque chose qui est souvent une
condition du succès c'est de la sentir
seul on est des animaux sociable on est
des animaux grégaires salon nous sommes
des animaux criaient et donc il ya
quelque chose qu'on a en horreur c'est
de se détacher du groupe donc réaliser
qu'on a un problème sur les bras et se
mettre le lendemain matin à se comporter
différemment au risque de se détacher du
groupe
c'est un truc qu'on n'aime pas du tout
et il ya des raisons neuronale assez
profonde au fait qu'on n'aime pas du
tout ça donc un des enjeux dans cette
affaire-là c'est d'arriver à faire les
choses ensemble
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'agir comme
consommateur citoyen et cetera si on est
d'entrée de jeu au sein d'un groupe qui
a envie d'agir dans la même direction
donc en fait pour l'individu une bonne
manière de passer à l'action c'est de se
rapprocher le groupe de gens qui
essayent de faire des choses concrètes
en général ça motive ça permet de rester
à animal sociable
tout en allant de l'avant il faut il
faut créer de la communauté autour de ça
du communautarisme et la communauté
c'est également vrai en ce qui concerne
le monde de l'entreprise c'est à dire
que c'est plus facile quand on fait les
choses à plusieurs donc on s'organise
avec son écosystème ses clients ses
fournisseurs et c'est bien évidemment
vrai dans le monde politique
on n'a pas envie de ralentir de se
couper de sa base électorale en se
mettant à proposer quelque chose de très
intelligent
sauf que les électeurs n'achèteront pas
une des raisons pour lesquelles monsieur
hollande a fait une des plus belles
conneries qu'il est fait c'est à dire
les 50% de nucléaire c'est tout
simplement parce qu'il avait une base
électorale dont il n'avait pas envie de
se couper et qu'il avait envie de gagner
et c'est plus fort que tout donc quand
on passe à l'action il ya quelque chose
qui est absolument crucial pour passer à
l'action c'est d'arriver à y aller en
groupe et j'ai envie de dire que c'est
un des défis qui se posent aux personnes
comme moi qui travaille dans le sujet au
quotidien c'est comment est ce qu'on
arrive à faire à faire affaire énergie
des collectivités qui ont envie de qui
ont envie d'avancer
c'est la raison du reste pour laquelle
je j'ai cofondé 44 et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai fondé de shit project
parce que c'est des organismes autour
desquels on peut créer des collectivités
et ça rend beaucoup plus facile l'envié
d'aller de l'avant j'ai dit à mes
joueurs auraient laissé la parole on va
laisser la parole daloa d'auditeurs qui
nous envahissent de question donc oui
merci j'ai l'échec at elle posé la
question je passe à eux j'essaie d'y
regrouper un petit peu pour qu'on essaie
de répondre au plus grand nombre
et je vais vous demander d'être assez
rapide dans les réponses pour qu'on
puisse traverser grand champ on est déjà
à plus de 50
juste pour vous dire avec des gens très
engagé qui vous remercie de votre
présentation déjà alors il ya toute une
toutain une série de questions qui
portent sur des carbonisé à l'aide
d'autres types d'énergie donc les
énergies renouvelables le rôle du
nucléaire là dedans et en partie la
politique de la france par rapport au
nucléaire
donc si vous pouvez nous parler un petit
peu de ça est votre vision sur la chose
en particulier avec un éclairage
français d'accord alors d'abord je vais
reprendre un tout petit peu une
perspective historique
il faut bien voir que ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons la
civilisation industrielle que nous avons
c'est justement parce qu'on est sorti
des énergies renouvelables les énergies
renouvelables étaient les seules
énergies dont on disposait il ya
quelques siècles
à l'époque nous n'avions que la force du
vent la force de l'eau les rayonnements
solaires la biomasse la traction animale
tout ça était parfaitement renouvelables
et à cette époque là la sophistication
de la société était beaucoup moins élevé
qu'aujourd'hui les gens qui étaient
occupés à extraire de l'énergie de
l'environnement sous forme
d'alimentation était beaucoup plus
importante qu'aujourd'hui et donc l'idée
qu'on va pouvoir conserver 8 milliards
d'hommes sur terre avec une fraction
significative de cette population qui
vit dans un monde industriel avec
uniquement des énergies renouvelables
est pour moi quelque chose qui est une
chimère
je ne crois pas que ce soit possible
donc le potentiel des énergies
renouvelables pour remplacer les
énergies fossiles à consommation
identique c'est impossible pour des
raison de limitations physiques parce
que le soleil et le vent y en a beaucoup
mais c'est très diffus et en fait c'est
parce que les énergies fossiles sont
très concentrés que l'on a pu les
utiliser de façon très intense c'est
beaucoup plus facile de transporter avec
soi un litre de pétrole que de
transporter avec soi des dizaines de
milliers de mètres cubes d'air en
mouvements compliqués c'est plus
compliqué le transporter avec soi du
rayonnement solaire et surtout la nuit
donc le la raison pour laquelle on est
passé aux énergies fossiles c'est parce
que c'est beaucoup plus puissant
beaucoup plus dense beaucoup plus simple
alors la traduction économique c'est que
ça coûte moins cher mais à la limite
c'est même pas ça le sujet le sujet
c'est là c'est la physique de base alors
est ce que pour autant il faut se priver
d'en utiliser non mais elles auront de
fortes limite on voit bien que en
particulier il ya un vrai sujet de
concurrence d'usagé des sols avec les
énergies renouvelables parce qu'en gros
les énergies renouvelables demande de
l'espace la biomasse sa demande de
l'espace l'hydraulique sa demande de
l'espace le plus grand lac de barrage au
monde il fait la superficie d'un
département français
donc c'est 5000 kilomètres carrés même
pas rien et donc le le sol air sa
demande de l'espace rien que pour faire
la quantité d'énergie solaire qui est
prévu dans la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie que nous
avons en france et qui va de faire
qu'une petite partie de l'électricité
qui ne fait elle même une petite partie
de l'énergie qu'on conserve d'accord eh
bien il faudra artificialisés de la
trois fois la superficie de paris et on
prend des surfaces de chambre aurait
elle qui on enlève tout ça et on vient
la place des panneaux solaires ont deux
à trois fois la superficie de paris rien
que pour ce cas dans la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qui va nous
faire passer le solaire de 5 à 20%
d'électricité qu'on utilise
si jamais on va au bout donc on est
l'électricité ça n'est que 20% de
l'énergie finale consommée en france et
20%
donc auquel pour machines donc le donc
on voit bien que c'est très gourmand en
espace cette affaire là et on voit bien
aussi avec l'éolien aujourd'hui l'éolien
déjà au niveau auquel il est commence à
poser des problèmes d'acceptabilité de
riverains qui disent on n'en veut plus
et c'est çà ne déprécie la valeur donc
le donc on voit bien que les énergies
renouvelables
en fait elles ont besoin d'espacé cet
espace on a du mal à le trouver sur une
planète qui est peuplée de 8 milliards
d'individus
alors reste le nucléaire le nucléaire
n'évitera pas dans la vision la décrue
économique où la contraction économique
liée à la contraction des énergies
fossiles que nous aurons degrés si on
décide que le climat est un problème
supra ou de force même si on décide pas
que le climat est après le supra parce
qu'à un moment la civilisation
s'effondrera ce moment où on sera en
pénurie d'énergies fossiles et donc elle
se vendra toute façon énorme parce que
c'était faisable
donc quand six est épuisable un jour on
va rentrer dans période donc je ne pense
pas que le nucléaire à lui tout seul
suffire à éviter ça parce qu'on part
trop tard il ya trop d'énergie fossile
consommée dans le monde
par contre ce que je crois c'est que
plus on en fait plus on amortit la
décroissance
donc j'ai coutume de dire que le
nucléaire est un amortisseur de la
décroissance
les gens qui disent amir décroissance
avec le bordel et on pourra pas gérer
nucléaire
jeudi bolt a complètement sûr parce que
l'ukraine a doublé son parc nucléaire
après la chute du mur dans un contexte
de division de son pib par deux quand
même gentil effondrement économique et
c'est pas à ce moment là qu'ils ont eu
des pépins
c'était avant c'était dans le régime
soviétique stable tchernobyl c'est dans
le régime soviétique stable on a demandé
aux opérateurs de faire une connerie
donc le l'idée que la décrue économiques
empêchent par construction d'avoir des
centrales qui fonctionnent je suis pas
sûr ça me paraît pas aussi simple que ça
comme argument donc le nucléaire est
pour moi un amortisseur de la
décroissance est il et
environnementalement plus intéressant
que les énergies renouvelables parce
qu'il est beaucoup plus économe en
surface en gros il faut 1000 fois moins
de surface pour faire de l'électricité
nucléaire que pour faire de
l'électricité solaire
donc on a moins ce problème de
concurrence visage des sols on n'est pas
moins dépendant des importations avec le
solaire parce qu'on apportait pas nous
donc avec le nucléaire on importe du
radium hockey a bien bien avec le
solaire on importe les panneaux je vois
pas où est la différence donc toute
façon on est dépendants de l'étranger
peuvent plus autonomes et si on
n'apportait pas les panneaux de toutes
façons devrait apporter le minerai de
fer le minerai de cuivre le minerai
d'aluminium pour les faire ce qu'on a
rien de tout ça en france bon donc
l'idée qu'on va devenir autonome
énergétiquement malheureusement ça ne
marche avec aucune énergie donc le sait
donc c'est beaucoup moins gourmand en
surface ça utilise 10 à 100 fois moins
de métal par kilowattheure produit donc
ça veut dire que c'est également moins
gourmand en ressources et ses ressources
il faut les sortir de mines ailleurs
alors c'est pas juste les terrasses et
les mettons dans boom du cuivre du etc
les premières mines de cuivre qu'on a
exploité à rio tinto en espagne elle
avait une teneur en minerai de 15%
aujourd'hui la teneur moyenne en cuivre
du minerai dans le monde c'est 0 5% en
anglais donc
donc on a eu des populations généralisée
de toutes façons une ressource dont
quelque chose qui est plus économe en
ressources est beaucoup plus intéressant
donc tout ça pour dire que
mondialement le nucléaire est une très
bonne idée
d'ailleurs qui remplace du charbon parce
que s'il vient se rajouter au charbon il
intéresse pas mais dès lors qu'il
remplace le charbon c'est une très bonne
idée
c'est une idée ça va plus vite de
construire du nucléaire que conscient du
solaire et d'éolien pour remplacer le
charbon c'est beaucoup plus dense
énergétiquement ça demande moins de
ressources ça suffira pas à éviter la
décroissance et en france
si je prends les problèmes de manière
très pratique la première des choses à
faire est prolongée le parc actuel
surtout ne pas fermer deux réacteurs
supplémentaires la fermeture de
fessenheim
c'est hollande qui a avancé une version
moderne de la vente du droit d'aînesse
pour un plat de lentilles
donc c'est ce qui a été fait par des
dirigeants qui pensent que l'énergie
c'est un truc technique qu'on donne à
des ingénieurs dans un coin il faut
prolonger les centrales actuelles et il
faut relancer ce qu'on appelle la
quatrième génération qui a justement été
abandonnée ya pas très longtemps par le
cher président macron pour faire la
jonction avec le nucléaire qu'on utilise
actuellement dans le monde qui n'est pas
un duclair extrêmement durable parce
qu'il utilise une trop petite partie de
l'uranium qu'on trouve dans la nature
il utilise juste un isotope qui est
l'isotope 235 et qui fait moins de 1 %
de l'uranium qu'on trouve dans la nature
pour pouvoir utiliser le reste et ça ça
veut dire passer à ce qu'on appelle la
quatrième génération
voilà donc si je fais donc les énergies
non carbonées oui il faut s'en servir
il faut s'en servir avec discrimination
par exemple en france développe et du
solaire et de l'éolien pour remplacer du
nucléaire n'a aucun intérêt sur aucun
plan
[Musique]
par contre développer le biogaz pour
remplacer l'essence des tracteurs des
agriculteurs
les tracts portent les agriculteurs ont
des tracteurs ça c'est pas idiot c'est
quelque chose qui macroéconomique mans
est pertinent et environnementalement et
pertinents par contre mettre ce gaz dans
le réseau pour remplacer le gaz fossile
pour nos chaudières à gaz c'est pas une
bonne idée il vaut mieux remplacer les
chaudières à gaz fossile par des pompes
à chaleur
voilà donc il faut être discriminée
la façon dont on utilise les énergies
décarbonées renouvelable au nucléaire il
faut bien voir qu'en france les
premières énergie qu'on doit décarbonés
c'est les énergies qui servent à faire
de la chaleur de la mobilité et de la
chaleur ou de température dans
l'industrie puisque l'électricité et
déjà décarbonée c'est pas la peine de la
décarbonés deuxième fois c'est une perte
de temps et perdre du temps quand on est
dans une course contre la montre s'est
augmenté ces risques donc il faut c'est
un tout manager à penser donc ce qu'il
faut c'est décarbonés la chaleur est
décarbonée la mobilité et ça là dedans
effectivement les énergies renouvelables
peuvent être utiles je le redis le
biogaz
les agrocarburants dans une certaine
limite on peut pas en faire beaucoup
parce qu'il ya une conférence d'alger
sur l'eau si voix la mémé c'est mais
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut toujours
regarder au droit d'un problème donné
donc il faut pas se dire les
renouvelables
globalement c'est génial le nucléaire
globalement c'est caca les fossiles
globalement c'est caca il faut regarder
les problèmes un par un et avoir quelque
chose d'un peu de discriminer quand on
s'intéresse à la au choix de ces
énergies renouvelables hydraulique
facilité par exemple c'est très bien ça
doit des vallées de montagne mais quand
on peut en faire c'est pas idiot merci
on a tout un tas de questions aussi sur
le modèle de croissance en fait que vous
préconisez préconiseriez qui serait
compatible en fait avec avec un avec une
augmentation à deux degrés seulement si
tenté que ça puisse être une possibilité
est donc dans quelle qu'elle est quel
est votre recommandation vous sur ce
modèle de princesse à quoi ça ressemble
quelque chose pour donner aussi d une
contribution plus positive à cela et il
ya des questions plus spécifiques sur
comment est-ce que ça s'articule avec
des questions comme celle des inégalités
et avec des questions comme celle de la
croissance démographique
voilà donc ça c'est je résume un
rapidement mais il ya pas mal de
questions autour de ça alors c'est
beaucoup de questions et beaucoup de
questions difficiles
oui beaucoup de questions difficiles
je vais commencer par la dernière au
premier rendre la pression de l'humanité
sur l'environnement elle est
proportionnelle au nombre de bons jeunes
à sur terre le diamètre de la planète
terre est constant au cours du temps
donc il était de 13 mille kilomètres il
ya deux siècles et malgré les génies du
marketing passé par l'insee à qui sera
toujours de 13 mille kilomètres dans
deux siècles change pas donc il ya une
table de repas qui a une taille donnée
et plus on est nombreux autour de la
table de repas et moins il y en a par
personne c'est juste arithmétique donc
ça veut dire que la hausse démographique
non contrôlée j'ai très très peur moi
que ça finisse en barbarie vraiment très
peur de ça alors pour le moment la
hausse des énergies fossiles a permis
transitoirement de faire en sorte que ça
ne se termine pas trop en barbarie parce
que en gros ça a permis d'augmenté
virtuellement la taille de la table de
repas mais ça va pas durer éternellement
donc on a un vrai sujet avec la
démographie alors c'est un débat qui est
difficile il ya quelques dizaines
d'années on n'hésite pas à en parler moi
je me rappelle d'un bouquin qui
s'appelle la bombe p qui a dû être
publiée comme toutes les grandes en
manifeste environnementaux dans les
années 70 70
c'est à ce moment là c'est très marrant
le début des années 70 c'est vraiment la
révolution environnementale
c'est à ce moment là que naissent ou
sonné peu avant tout les grandes ong
environnementales qui a aujourd'hui
c'est à ce moment là qu'est publié le
fameux rapport limitrophes qui a fait
tant de bruit à l'époque s'est passé il
ya vraiment c'est à ce moment là que on
allait premier candidat écologiste aux
élections présidentielles donc il ya
vraiment il s'est passé quelque chose
j'ai jamais eu le temps de creuser dans
le détail mais il s'est passé quelque
chose à la fin des années 60 début des
années 70 qui fait qu'il ya vraiment et
c'est aussi à ce moment là qui est
publié un bouquin qui s'appelle la bombe
p et qui explique que la planète va vers
un état de surpopulation
alors aujourd'hui on n'en parle plus
mais en fait la planète est surpeuplée
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'elle ne peut
malheureusement par accueillir 8
milliards d'individus pour un de siècle
ça marche pas alors maintenant une fois
j'ai dit ça j'ai rien dit parce que j'ai
pas de solution évidente pour gérer le
problème est par contre
je pense que à l'évidence nous sommes
dans un état instable
ce qu'on peut faire c'est essayer
d'éviter d'en rajouter ou moins donc
tout ce qu'on peut faire pour éviter de
donner envie aux genres d'avoir un
enfant à mon avis est quelque chose qui
n'est pas complètement inutile même s'il
dit comme ça ça peut paraître un peu
désagréable et un peu voilà mais je
pense que en tout cas on mérite d'avoir
un débat adultes sur la question
aujourd'hui juste on l'a pas après en ce
qui concerne la croissance
alors mon modèle de croissance si on
veut respecter les deux degrés je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est un modèle de
décroissance si les émissions en baisse
de 5% par an ça veut dire que la
quantité d'énergie fossiles qu'on
utilise baisse de 5% par an ça veut dire
que la quantité d'énergie tout court
qu'on utilise n'est pas loin de baisser
de 5% par an et on 4 ça veut dire que le
parc de machines en service dans le
monde se contracte de 4 % par an puisque
l'énergie c'est la nourriture des
machines et donc ça veut dire que la
production économique baisse aux
artefact comptable près l'inflation des
actifs la valeur des actions de tesla
enfin bref aux artefact comptable près
mais qui aujourd'hui font une large part
de la croissance du pib ça veut dire que
le pib vrai baril baisse de 3 4% par an
voilà ce que ça veut dire
donc les deux degrés c'est arithmétique
à ce que j'ai à vous dire c'est pas
idéologique c'est juste tel qui est
construit pib est tel que tel que tel
que fonctionne physiquement le monde et
la production avec des machines alors
est-ce que ça ça doit désespérer
billancourt c'est ça la bonne question
le mari bon c'est que comme de toute
façon on va se le prendre ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure que je ne croyais pas
à la croissance perpétuelle
la seule bonne question pour moi c'est
comment on l'anticipé comment on
commence à s'organiser pour que ça soit
gérable
alors une première manière que ce soit
gérable c'est d'arrêter d'être obsédé
par ça parce que si vous êtes obsédé par
votre jeunesse et que vous vieillissez
c'est juste insupportable si vous êtes
obsédés par la vitesse à laquelle vous
parcourez le 100 mètres et que sa baisse
tous les ans c'est juste insupportable
donc plus on est obsédé par la
croissance et plus ça sera insupportable
quand ça va se mettre à aller dans le
mauvais sens absolument absolument
évident donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on ait des plans pour l'avenir qui
résiste à la contraction du pib
voilà c'est juste ça que ça veut dire
que ça ne doit plus être un indicateur
incarnant le bonheur c'est un indicateur
comptable très bien et les banques qui
vont tibet si baisse il faut pas qu'ils
incarnent le bonheur alors
malheureusement il a car quand même un
peu l'aisance matérielle
parce que quand le pib augmente c'est à
dire que les plus de mètres carrés c'est
bien volé plus de voiture et ça veut
dire que j'avais plus de bancs et donc
il va falloir qu'on se construisent un
imaginaire dans lequel collectif dans
lequel dans un certain nombre de
domaines à voir - est vu comme étant
mieux qu'avoir plus quand je prends un
exemple vous avez un certain nombre de
gens aujourd'hui pour qui avoir un vélo
plutôt qu'une voiture c'est mieux c'est
mieux parce qu'ils disent bon voilà je
fais un peu d'exercice le matin avant
d'aller au boulot j'arrive je suis plus
détendu j'ai pas le propre j'ai pas de
stress d'avoir regardé ma bagnole ça me
coûte moins cher alors évidemment si
avec l'argent qu'ils ont économisé près
de l'avion on n'est pas plus avancés sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mais si avec ça elle s'achète de la
nourriture de boeuf qui en a fait des
papouilles hors de prix voilà
globalement quand même ils ont réduit
leur empreinte carbone donc le donc on
va vraiment avoir besoin et c'est là que
j'en reviens au discours politique
on va avoir besoin de trouver un moyen
de d'avoir foi en l'avenir d'avoir
confiance en l'avenir de le regarder
avec espoir et envie
avec dans un certain nombre de domaines
- alors il ya des cas de figure où ça
nous arrive déjà je veux dire il ya des
gens par exemple il quitte pendant les
vacances
leurs domiciles confortable pour aller
sous une tente
pour aller se mettre dans un van pour
faire du surf c'est pourquoi ils ont
ravi donc transitoirement ils ont vécu
dans des conditions matérielles beaucoup
plus spartiate est quand même très
content parce qu'ils ont vu autre chose
à côté
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui le défi qui
se pose à ceux qui revendique d'avoir la
conduite des affaires de la nation dont
je fais partie je me mets dedans puisque
en étant président d'une association qui
cherche d'influx je t'en fais partie eh
bien nous sommes obligés moi inclus
d'avoir un discours qui est qu'est-ce
que je peux raconter comme histoire où
les gens sont pas mécontents d'avoir
moins voilà qu'est ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on peut alors avoir moins sur le plan
strictement matériel aujourd'hui vous
avez par exemple un certain nombre de
gens qui ont tellement envie de sortir
des villes qui sont prêts à voir parce
qu'ils étouffent et en fait on peut
expliquer aussi pourquoi
neurologiquement si on aime on n'aime
pas être en ville qu'ils sont 10 m ils
sont tellement ils ont tellement envie
qu'eux ils sont prêts à baisser leurs
revenus pour sortir de la ville c'est
des gens qui sont prêts à faire sa ba
voilà des gens qui sont construit tout
seul un imaginaire dans lequel ils se
sentent mieux dans un monde dans lequel
ils ont moins acheté de trucs mais ce
alors ira bien quand même parce que ils
auront à côté de ça gagne et l'air pur
l'espace le fait de faire une autre
activité qui préfère cultiver de la
ligne il trouve ça plus agréable que ce
qu'ils faisaient avant
le comptable donc il ya il ya un an
il ya déjà des gens qui sont qui ce qui
se met dans cette logique et je pense
que c'est ça en fait le défi qui nous
attend c'est comment est ce que je suis
capable de raconter une histoire dans
laquelle je sais gérer parce que c'est
pas ça notre premier problème le fait
que sur un plan strictement monétaire
les revenus se contractent voilà c'est
ça le défi alors il est pas mal ça comme
des filles j'en conviens bien la
meilleure manière de pas le résoudre
c'est pas si attaquer donc ce qu'on est
en train de faire en ce moment c'est
très exactement perdre notre temps tous
les économistes de la terre qui se
demandent simplement comment faire
revenir la croissance
ils sont en train de perdre leur temps
parce que c'est pas ça le problème qu'on
a à traiter
on a à traiter c'est comment j'organise
la société sans qu'elles ces fonds dans
un contexte dans lequel après avoir cru
le pib décroît
dernier point et non des moindres il
faut bien voir que le pib est un
indicateur de flux c'est pas un
indicateur de richesse le pib c'est un
indicateur de
puisque c'est la contrepartie économique
du flux annuel de transformation donc la
vraie richesse c'est le stock et là je
vais vous faire un petit parallèle qui
vous montrent que lui le stock glock
prix globalement plus on produit plus
ubs vite
oui je vous allez voir vous avez bien
évidemment entendu parler de la station
spatiale internationale
la station spatiale internationale est
une grosse boîte de conserve qui se
promènent à quelques centaines de
kilomètres au dessus de nos têtes ou
monsieur pesquet il passait ses vacances
de temps en temps et qui a coûté de
l'ordre d'une centaine de milliards de
dollars pour être construite est lancé
d'accord 100 milliards de dollars
alors pour 100 milliards de dollars
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous avez la
possibilité de créer dans un endroit où
ça n'existe pas une pression
atmosphérique d'une atmosphère puisque à
quelques centaines de kilomètres
d'altitude d'un pression atmosphérique
n'est pas vraiment d'une atmosphère
beaucoup moins ça vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir un air respirable
avec l'important d'oxygène d'air de
danse que vous n'avez pas 300 km
d'altitude
vous avez une température qui est
compatible avec les animaux régulier à
37 degrés que nous sommes parce que
toujours pareil à cet endroit là et une
température extérieure qui est pas
vraiment celle qui nous faut et c'est à
peu près tout si vous pouvez vous pouvez
prendre des photos mais donc pour 100
milliards de dollars c'est-à-dire 15
milliards de dollars par astronaute
puisque vous avez six personnes dans la
station spatiale internationale
vous avez un air respirable une pression
à une atmosphère un début de cycle de
l'eau et encore même vos urines et purée
ça suffit pas tant s'en faut en année
par vaisseau cargo de l'eau et c'est que
vous n'avez pas de sols cultivables vous
n'avez pas de rouge gorge
vous n'avez pas le coucher de soleil sur
la baie de quiberon rien et juste vous
allez donc on peut très bien argumenté
le fait que la planète terre vaille au
moins 15 milliards de dollars par
personne
d'accord puisque qu'un milliard de
dollars c'est déjà le prix d'une
atmosphère respirable du fait que vous
soyez pas à -50 degrés et donc la
planète terre au moins 15 milliards de
dollars par personne et au travers de
nos activités productives
on en détruit au moins un pour mille
tous les ans tous les ans on détruit 1
pour mille du stock de pointe au moins -
du stock du regard du heures du stock de
minerai
des fois beaucoup plus que ça du stock
de sol du stock de fort allait lui et
c'est donc moi je peux vous dire moi le
compoix le commissaire aux comptes de la
terre je vous dis pas très bien vous
allez me passer 15 millions de dollars
de provisions pour dépréciations
d'apporter de provision pour
amortissements enfin de dotations aux
amortissements voilà pour consommation
des espaces naturels par tête de pipe et
en face de ça vous avez un pib par
personne qui a envoyé deux mondial fait
quinze mille dollars
donc vous voyez qu'avec une convention
comptable pas plus idiot que l'autre moi
je vous dit en fait la croissance c'est
un appauvrissement
on croit qu'on s'enrichit mais non on
s'appauvrit parce que le jour où
l'énergie sera plus là et bien les
actifs naturels qui aurait permis de
retour fin de hrw au moins de revenir au
stade où on en était avant même nom mais
leur a plu donc la question de quel
modèle de croissance il faut bien
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
réflexion durban totalement déconnectée
des flux physiques et ou la nourriture
arrive dans le supermarché et les
fringues dans le magasin mais en fait on
peut déjà montré qu'en fait cette
croissance s'est juste conventionnel
j'ai commencé la croissance des bagnoles
et des immeubles d'accord est ce que
c'est la croissance de la totalité des
actifs à votre disposition discuter sans
transition on a aussi plusieurs
questions sur le rôle de la capture du
carbone et ce quelle est votre position
par rapport à ça et il ya une sous
question la capture dans le sol lié à de
nouveaux d'autres formes de
d'utilisation du sol pour l'agriculture
de permaculture
alors il ya 2 il ya deux manières je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure de retirer le
carbone enfin le car mais le co2 à deux
manières de se retirer d'atmosphère
c'est qu'ils viennent en contact avec
des êtres végétaux et à ce moment il ya
la photosynthèse qui le récupère ou qu'
il soit dissous dans l'océan alors quand
il est dissout dans l'océan hilda
signifie ce qu'un certain nombre
d'espèces qui vivent dans l'océan n'aime
pas trop ce qu'on imagine alors il ya
deux techniques
quand on parle de capture du carbone qui
sont évoqués il ya empêcher le co2
d'aller dans l'air et ça c'est des
dispositifs
on imagine m en sortie de
installation de combustion en
particulier les centrales électriques ou
les cimenteries aujourd'hui vous avez
sur terre chaque année de l'ordre de 40
milliards de tonnes de co2 qui sont
émises et vous avez aujourd'hui des
dispositifs de capture du co2 pour
environ 40 millions de tonnes
donc un pour mille quand vous êtes dans
une entreprise ou un pur ou quelque
chose représente 1 pour mille du chiffre
d'affaires vous vous dites que à tout le
moins vous pouvez pas compter là dessus
pour remplacer ce qui fait tout le reste
du chiffre d'affaires dans les cinq ans
qui viennent
donc c'est peut-être pas idiot de
développer ce genre de choses
par contre ce qui est sûr c'est que font
pas attendre que ce soit prêt pour
commencer à agir sur le reste donc est
ce à ce que je dis là est vrai d'une
manière générale pour plein de marge de
manoeuvre technologique pour lequel ça
sera peut-être vrai ça sera peut être
prêt dans vingt ans dans 20 30 40 ans
bah ouais sauf que si ces prêts dont 40
en valeur dans 40 ans les émissions où
elle est nulle donc si ces prêts pendant
40 ans et c'est trop tard il faut que ce
soit prêt pour dans beaucoup moins
longtemps que ça ça n'empêche pas en
même temps de préparer des choses qui
prendront le relais dans 40 ans mais ça
peut pas être la mesure principale
d'action la deuxième chose à laquelle on
pense c'est remettre du carbone dans les
sols agricoles or il se trouve que ce
qui déstocke le carbone des sols
agricoles c'est essentiellement le
labourage quand vous labourer le sol en
fait on fait ça pourquoi on fait ça pour
enfouir les mauvaises herbes
c'est une technique de désherbage
labourier comme ça tout ce qui pousse à
la surface de la terre crack se
retrouvent enfouis saveurs et du coup
vous pouvez semer ce qui vous intéresse
par dessus en plus ces meubles comme ça
vous vous installez la graine facilement
le alors que sinon dans la nature vous
voyez bien que l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles les arbres font des milliers
de milliards de graines c'est parce que
comme le solides urbains il faut bien ça
pour que vous finissiez par en avoir eu
lui qui germe de temps en temps
puis qui finissent par percer à travers
le feuillage sauf que dans l'agriculture
on n'a pas envie qu'il y ait un grain de
blé de temps en temps qui germe ou non
et qui charme tous et donc c'est quand
même plus simple de labourage et pour
que tous toujours et que le sol soit
capable alors le les techniques de
reprise du carbone dans le sol c'est
d'abord d'arrêter de labourer et c'est
ensuite les techniques qui s'appelle
d'agroforesterie c'est à dire que vous
plantez vous remets ddm
et donc vous avez des racines il est
raciste du carbone que vous allez mettre
de plus en plus dans le sol c'est
également des techniques dans lesquelles
vous augmentez la biomasse de vers de
terre les vers de terre c'est une des
premières biomasse sur terre dans les
sols fortement labourer et fortement
traités etc
vous en avez beaucoup moins donc le fait
de remettre des gardes car dans le sol
c'est également quelque chose qui vous
augmente le carbone alors c'est pas
idiot évidemment de planter les arbres
qui vont prendre du co2 dans l'air et
ensuite ils vont faire pousser leurs
racines et puis les racines vont se
mettre dans le pilot de même le jour où
vous couper là pour faire du bois de
ceux où j'ai pas quoi vous lui coupez
ses branches ses racines sur toujours là
accessoirement ça vous limite également
l'érosion des simples choses voilà comme
ça c'est que ça c'est les techniques de
reprise du co2 de l'atmosphère pour le
mettre dans le sol
les techniques qui empêchent le co2
d'aller dans l'atmosphère sont guettés
cessé d'exciter technologique cette
affaire là et ça demande de capturer le
co2 en sortie de en sortie de cheminée
alors comme le co2 est une molécule
inerte c'est je faisais tout à leur
capture est une molécule inerte c'est un
truc qui chimiquement n'est jamais
simple
parce qu'en fait ce que vous savez bien
capturé ces les molécules réactive donc
vous les faites s'associer avec autre
chose
et au moment où elle passe craque elle
se marie avec un autre truc qui passait
par là
ça vous fait un nouveau composé et se
composer lui est stable et vous arrivez
à récupérer et si idéalement il est
solide ou liquide
c'est très facile de le garder sur terre
mais quand vous avez un composé qui est
inerte comme le co2 à ses groupies
compliqué d'arriver à capturer en fait
vous y arrivez avec des dispositifs qui
eux mêmes vont consommer d'énergie et en
pratique l'énergie qui est nécessaire
pour capturer le co2 une centrale par
exemple se balade entre 15 et 30% de
l'énergie thermique de la centrale donc
c'est pas c'est pas du tout négligeable
et ça veut dire que ces 15 à 30% ne sont
plus là pour produire de l'électricité
par exemple
donc si vous mettez cette technique en
oeuvre à large échelle sur les centrales
existantes
ça veut dire que vous avez besoin
d'augmenter le nombre de centrales pour
compenser la différence où vous avez
besoin à laval d'engendrer des économies
d'énergie importantes
enfin des économies d'électricité en
l'occurrence importante pour compenser
la perte s'est essentiellement sarr le
problème de la capture du co2 qui par
ailleurs sa demande des grosses
installations qui sont volumineuses
qu'il faut avoir l'espace pour les
maîtres et enfin il faut avoir un
endroit où mettre le co2 une fois que
vous l'avez capturé parce qu'une fois
que vous l'avez capturés en fait vous le
compresser pour le rendre ce qu'on
appelle supercritique qu'en gros liquide
et sans viscosité c'est ça le super
critique et vous l'injecter dans le sous
sol mais il faut avoir un endroit où
l'injecter il faut évidemment que les
gens soient suffisamment convaincu que
c'est une bonne idée pourquoi que vous
ayez un milliard de procès sur la figure
avant d'y arriver
bref donc ces trucs-là soulan donc oui
technologiquement c'est possible
maintenant d'ici à ce que je meurs ça ne
constituera pas une marge de manoeuvre
première dans l'ensemble ce qu'il faut
faire
ça ira beaucoup plus vite d'essayer de
convaincre les gens que c'est une bonne
idée et se mettre au vélo et il ya aussi
tout un groupe de questions sur
l'hydrogène donc ça et que je vous pose
aussi le rôle de l'hydrogène dans ce
débat et est-ce qu'on a raison de
s'emballer sur l'hydrogène l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui est un gascon connaît bien
dans le monde de la chimie parce que
fabriquer de l'hydrogène
c'est dans le monde
[Musique]
motivé par deux grandes applications qui
sont d'une part des sulfures et les
carburants
vous savez que vous avez une
réglementation sur les carburants
automobiles
le diesel ou l'essence qui fait que ces
carburants doivent être raisonnablement
exempt de soufre or dans le pétrole vous
avez dû souffrent parce que le pétrole
étant le résidu d'une décomposition de
d'organismes anciens du plancton bas
dans les êtres vivants et du soufre dans
monsieur de bettignies un peu de soufre
et heureusement il me sens pas le
souffle un peu et dans mon organisme il
ya aussi un peu de souffle et donc le
soufre une fois que il est dans le
pétrole il faut l'enlever parce que
sinon ça vous fait de la pollution
locale avec du so2 et pour enlever le
soufre on a besoin d'hydrogène
c'est ça qu'on fait dans l'est dans les
raffineries on utilise danger comme
réactif pour enlever le soufre donc 40%
en hydrogène qu'on fait dans le monde
sert à ça il 40% de l'hydrogène qu'on
fait dans le monde sert à fabriquer les
engrais n'est objectivement arabique et
de l'ammoniac l'ammoniac cnh 3 un atome
d'azoté trois atomes d'hydrogène et pour
fabriquer cette ammoniac comprend la
zone dans l'air et on prend l'hydrogène
dans le méthane le gaz naturel en fait
fabriquer d'hydrogène on sait très bien
le faire aujourd'hui
on mélange du méthane et de la vapeur
d'eau on chauffe tout ça à très haute
température et ça finit par vous donner
de l'hydrogène et du co2 donc fabriqué
d'hydrogène on sait très bien faire et
ça fait dix tonnes de co2 pour une bonne
d'hydrogène
donc si vous utilisez aujourd'hui une
voiture à hydrogène avec de l'hydrogène
fait de cette manière ça fait plus de
co2 qu'une voiture à pétrole donc
l'hydrogène il n'est pas propre par
nature parce que vous n'avez que de la
vapeur d'eau dans la voiture il est
aussi propre aussi sale que la manière
de le faire c'est exactement comme
l'électricité l'électricité est aussi
propre ou sale que la manière de la
faire si on veut avoir de l'hydrogène
pour remplacer les carburants routiers
avec de l'hydrogène fait par électrolyse
et 7 électrolyse elle-même fait avec de
l'électricité décarbonée j'ai fait un
petit calcul d'ordre de grandeur pour la
france si on veut remplacer les
carburants routiers par de l'hydrogène
il faut doubler la production électrique
française pour faire pour
voilà donc on peut le faire on n'en
prend pas vraiment le chemin si on peut
le faire
voilà et après vous avez logistique de
l'hydrogène qui est une logistique qui
est complexe parce que l'hydrogène
il se trouve que c'est le gaz
inflammable qui est le moins denses
énergétiquement par unité de volume
si vous prenez un mètre cube d'hydrogène
à température et pression ambiante
eh bien vous avez moins d'énergie en le
brûlant que si vous prenez un véhicule
de méthane dans lequel il ya lui-même
moins d'énergie que si vous prenez un
mètre cube de d'éthane dans lequel il ya
mètre cube de propane et c'est donc dans
un véhicule d'hydrogène c'est là que
vous avez le moins d'énergie dans tous
les gaz inflammables or la logistique de
gaz c'est de l'énergie sur le compresser
faut le transporter et c'est tout ça
c'est de l'énergie donc l'hydrogène et
le gaz avec lequel vous allez avoir le
plus mauvais rendement énergétique dans
sa manutention
d'accord c'est plus mauvais que le
méthane et c'est évidemment beaucoup
plus mauvais que le pétrole qui lui ad à
une manutention extrêmement simple
puisque c'est liquide à température et
pression ambiante et donc la dépense
énergétique que vous avez pour
transporter et stocker du pétrole est
extrêmement faible
c'est la raison pour laquelle solide en
passant le pétrole la seule énergie
mondiale vraiment mondiale que nous
ayons parce que c'est extrêmement facile
à transporter et à stocker en utilisant
très très peu d'énergie donc l'hydrogène
gel vous donner un ordre de grandeur
c'est quelque chose qui est donc on peut
en faire un peu alors en fait
l'hydrogène là où c'est le plus simple
ou le plus pertinent de l'utiliser une
fois qu'on en a fait avec de l'électro
lise c'est pas du tout pour faire
avancer des voitures et des avions
les avions on en fera moins c'est pas
très grave les gens feront au moins le
tour de la terre il faut au moins le
tour de la terre c'est juste pas grave
je dire pendant des centaines de
milliards pour des dizaines de milliers
d'années
on a vécu sans à lyon et même pendant
toute l'époque de l'humanité jusqu'à ya
40 ans ou 50 ans on a vécu ça en devient
donc très grave de vie sans avion on
veut garder quelques avions quelques
années je veux dire on n'a pas besoin
les cohortes de touristes qui se
précipitent dans les grands magasins
parisiens
hâtivement persuadé que ce soit
totalement indispensable au bonheur de
l'humanité donc et les cordes de
français qui vont retrouver d'autres
français au club med pas non plus je
suis sûr que ça on peut très bien s'en
accommoder de faire avec moi 75% du
trafic de passagers dans l'avion c'est
du trafic de loisirs donc pas s'occupe
dire on passe notre temps mais on peut
s'occuper autrement barre en sanglots
scène pour ce qui concerne les voitures
c'est pareil c'est une bonne partie des
voitures les deux tiers de la mobilité
motorisée en voiture c'est de la
mobilité du quotidien c'est aller au
boulot aller faire les courses aller et
ses ballades dans hot chip projet qu'on
à regarder ça de très très près vous en
avez une très grande quantité qu'on peut
remplacer par d'autres modes de
déplacement c'est à dire la combinatoire
marche à pied et vélo vélo électrique
éventuellement scooters électriques
voitures partagées on en garde mes
voitures partagées transports en commun
avec une combinatoire de cette nature
vous pouvez diviser les émissions de la
mobilité quotidienne par 3,4 sans avoir
besoin de l'hydrogène et ça ira beaucoup
plus vite de changer l'organisation des
transports et de changer ce cas dans la
tête des gens donc il pense pas que
c'est dégradant d'aller au boulot à vélo
électrique plutôt qu'en voiture ou qui
pense pas que ces lieux pour cent plus
sympa je pense que ça ira plus vite que
de compter sur l'hydrogène pour qu'on
reste tous dans une tonne et demie de
bagnols à utiliser les unes derrière les
autres pour aller au travail qui ont eu
trente secondes nerveux donc le les
embouteillages légendaires veut donc le
l'hydrogène
l'application dans laquelle ça sera le
plus intéressant c'est si on veut s'en
servir dans le domaine industriel
alors on peut décarbonés l'hydrogène
pour continuer à faire des engrais parce
que le temps qu'on retrouve suffisamment
d'animaux de trait pour faire caca dans
les champs il va quand même se passer du
temps donc de conserver des engrais
azotés de synthèse c'est quand même pas
idiot même si ils font en utiliser moins
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas idiot de
continuer à en avoir
il reflète en avoir besoin pour manger
et puis là même avec mme jiang et puis
la deuxième chose dans laquelle c'est
pas idiot c'est éventuellement pour
faire de l'acier parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'acier utilise 15% du charbon mondial
dans les hauts fourneaux
c'est la deuxième industrie la plus
émettrice de co2 après quasiment fait 2
milliards de tonnes d'acier par an et le
minerai de fer c'est à dire de l'oxydé
de fer
on peut imaginer le réduire avec de
l'hydrogène plutôt que de le réduire
avec du carbone réduire c'est enlever
l'oxygène c'est la réaction chimique qui
consiste à enlever d'oxygène d'un oxyde
les suédois on m'avait ont décidé
d'investir 40 milliards de dollars mais
c'est pas rien dans un projet d'acier
sans carbone enfin cent de réduction du
minerai de fer l'hydrogène ils sont
lancé là dedans c'est un projet public
sarah mon avis est intéressant de
regarder aussi et quand on regarde les
ordres de grandeurs s'est pas
complètement déconnant on se dit
qu'effectivement on peut continuer
pendant un certain temps à faire de
l'acier sans émettre de co2 avec ce
procédé là et là vous n'avez pas de
mesures de substitution évidence si vous
voulez de l'acier et tant qu'on aura
besoin de fourchette pour éviter de
faire des tâches sur la crac pas
complètement idiot d'avoir de vaciller
eh bien on aura quelques quelques
machines à laver ça fait partie des
éléments de confort pas complètement
inintéressant eh bien on aura besoin
d'acier et cet acier il a bien falloir
le faire et donc il faudrait idéalement
le faire sans co2 donc l'hydrogène de ce
point de vue est intéressant l'hydrogène
dans les transports je pense que avant
que ça devienne une nécessité on a
énormément d'autres marges de manoeuvre
à notre disposition plutôt que de miser
sur ce qui pour moi relève quand même de
la fuite en avant technologique dont on
peut raisonnablement parier en tout cas
moi je suis prêt à le faire que ça ne
sera pas au rendez vous de la promesse
faite vous est clair sur les solutions
technologiques sur lesquels il faut
justement pas trop s'emballer on va
devoir
on va devoir boucler bientôt il ya
énormément de questions qu'on n'a pas pu
aborder mais en particulier peut-être
rapidement en termes de qui fait quoi
et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire en tant qu
en tant que citoyen lambda qui ferait
que peut-on faire pour réveiller nos
politiques au niveau de l'urgence
et dans nos propres habitudes on avait
pas mal de questions sur nos propres
habitudes de consommation est ce que ça
change vraiment quelque chose qu'on peut
faire nous en tant que citoyens
individuels bijou est utile et qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour réveiller nos
politiques sur cette question là je
pense qu'on peut être bouclée avec celle
là alors je là dessus je vais avoir des
réponses extrêmement pratique on me
pardonnera de faire un tout petit peu
d'auto promotion 44 a mis en ligne il ya
pas très longtemps un outil qui
s'appelle maisi ottou qui est un outil
dans lequel on prend conscience de ce
qu'est son empreinte carbone individuel
donc en gros d'où viennent les émissions
qui sont associés à ce qu'on fait dans
la journée la façon dont on se déplace
la façon dont dont on mange ce qu'on
achète etc
et c'est un outil qu'on a conçu alors
non pas comme un calculateur que les
gens peuvent utiliser tout seuls dans
leur coin parce que là on sait que de
toute façon l'action derrière suivra pas
mais justement on en a fait un outil
collectif d'entrée de jeu donc ça
fonctionne sur la base de réunions
tupperware
donc en gros c'est laisser des réunions
de groupe où il ya un animateur qui
présente les outils et tout le monde
fait ensemble en même temps le calcul
évidemment il ya un petit effet
d'entraînement etc on déstabilise pas
les gens mais c'est intéressant et les
gens qui ont fait quelques unes ou de
conférences de cette nature peuvent même
devenir derrière ambassadeur une petite
formation pour ça et aller animer des
groupes ailleurs et c'est donc c'est un
truc et virales par groupe
c'est un peu comme la fresque du climat
pour ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent
c'est un truc virale par groupe c'est
l'effet doppler ware et c'est quelque
chose qui permet de prendre conscience
de là où sont ses émissions une fois
qu'on prend conscience de la boue sur
ses émissions commencent à se poser la
question est ce que ça me coûterait
beaucoup de faire différemment ce que je
peux est ce que ça coûterait beaucoup je
regarde par exemple que pour tous les
gens qui mettent les pieds dans l'avion
une fois par an un des premiers trucs
dutil qui peuvent faire en ce moment le
kobe de dz
c'est de moins prendre l'avion voir
depuis le prendre l'avion moi ça fait 20
ans que je ne monte plus dans un avion
sous la torture
donc je les prie quelquefois soit parce
que je pensais que professionnellement
j'avais beaucoup plus de co2 à éviter en
allant voir les gens je devais aller
voir qu'en montant dans l'avion et c'est
très peu fréquents j'en suis
systématiquement toutes les conférences
à l'étranger où il faut prendre l'avion
par exemple mais c'est c'est quelquefois
là si vous êtes vous prenez également
conscience des achats il ya des tas de
gens qui sont des acheteurs
je vais pas dire compulsif mais il
réfléchit on veut faire plaisir je sache
est un truc et c'est là vous vous rendez
compte que des trucs que vous achetez
fall a bien fallu les fabriquer est donc
qu'est ce que vous en avez vraiment
besoin
est ce que vous allez foncièrement plus
heureux derrière ou est ce que vous
allez faire un tour en forêt sens
appareils quoi donc
donc elle sait qu'on peut faire un titre
personnel c'est vivre cette expérience
après la deuxième chose qu'on peut faire
à titre personnel c'est se demander si
on est bien dans le travail qu'on fait
et alors là il ya un site qui vient
d'être mis en ligne par les personnes
physiques amis du chief project qui
s'appelle les shifters qui s'appelle
shift sur job
donc c'est en anglais un shift your job
tous à attacher points alors que si ma
mémoire est bonne et qui recense toutes
les entités qui font quelque chose qui
normalement va plutôt dans la bonne
direction
quand il s'agit de s'attaquer à la
question du changement climatique alors
rentré dans une entreprise comme ça
évidemment c'est tout de suite rejoins
d'une collectivité de gens avec laquelle
lesquels normalement on partage des
choses donc c'est clair que s'investir
au travers de son travail c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est très important et
quelqu'un qui se sent pas bien dans le
travail qu'il fait aujourd'hui parce que
sinon je peux pas supporter d'être au
service de ce truc là parce que au fond
ça n'a pas de sens
une fois qu'il a dit ça il n'a rien dit
s'il n'a pas un autre endroit où aller
ou auxquels il peut envisager d'aller
etc on a mis ça en ligne et les gens
peuvent faire des suggestions donc c'est
aussi un truc qui est collaboratif
environ par les suggestions pour non
content j'ai fait pas qu'une boîte dix
mois je suis verte pour qu'on vive ouais
c'est bien sûr le site c'est l'idée
l'idée là donc ça c'est pour en ce qui
concerne les individus donc les
individus ils ont leur consommation leur
job après ils ont leur vote alors leur
vote malheureusement il faut qu'il
rencontre une offre je vais vous faire
une confidence depuis que je vote
les uns sur les 20 dernières années je
n'ai jamais voté pour un candidat
autrement que la mort dans l'âme encore
jamais trouvé
même les verts trop ce qu'il raconte est
incohérent donc je n'ai jamais voté
autrement que la mort dans l'âme pour un
candidat ou une candidate
donc là malheureusement si vous n'avez
pas l'offre vous avez pas l'offre quoi
je veux dire vous pouvez rien y faire
donc la tâche compliquée et puis les
gens qui sont prêts à créer leur propre
parti pour avoir l'offre
il ya quand même pas beaucoup parce que
c'est un chemin de croix de commencer à
faire ce genre de choses
si vous voulez pas trop vous
compromettre est resté à peu près entier
la fosse aux lions le monde politique
en ce qui me concerne ça comptant les
bords de loin tant le après vous savez
ce que vous pouvez faire dans votre
métier
alors s'il se trouve là ça envoie ce que
j'ai tout à l'heure que vous êtes déjà
un poste de responsabilité
voilà j'ai envie de dire votre devoir
presque votre devoir ces belles pas un
luxe quoi quand vous savez qu'il ya un
gros paquet de l'expression au paquet de
merde qui s'annonce le devoir de tout
chef d'entreprise responsable tout
dirigeant d'entreprise responsable le
tout cas pour responsable ou toutes
personnes en responsabilité responsable
et de commencer à essayer de comprendre
ce que ça peut vouloir dire pour son
activité donc là les méthodes existent
ça veut dire faire une empreinte carbone
ça veut dire faire une scénarisation
prospective ou un ensemble de
scénarisation prospective pour
comprendre ce que ça veut dire deux fils
d'évoluer dans un monde où les émissions
baisse de 5% par an ça s'appelle une
scénarisation 2° c des méthodes
physiques c'est pas des méthodes
économiques qui permettent de faire ça
c'est très bien faire ça à 44 un peu
d'auto promo donc et une fois que vous
avez compris où est le problème barre à
ce moment c'est là que la vraie vie
commence et c'est une vie de compromis
vous n'allez pas pouvoir faire
instantanément tout ce que vous voudriez
faire il faudrait que vos clients soient
d'accord éventuellement qu'ils soient
d'accord pour payer plus cher sur
l'accord pour penser la même chose
où en trouver de nouveaux
entre ou éventuellement est d'accord
pour l'avoir - évidemment pas facile en
bref donc c'est là que les vrais les
vraies difficultés commencent mais au
début et des états et le décompte
donc au début il faut il faut comprendre
avec des méthodes et des outils
lorsque je dis est vrai dans une
entreprise ordinaire c'est vrai dans une
association
c'est vraiment là c'est vrai dans la
sphère publique c'est vrai dans le monde
financier
partout il ya des méthodes qui sont
basés sur un peu le même corpus
méthodologique qui permettent de
comprendre recommence comment se
présente le donc voila voila en gros les
quelques réponses que je peux faire que
je peux faire rapidement
ce que je peux vous dire parce que c'est
mon expérience c'est que les gens qui
commencent à comprendre qu'il commence à
avoir envie de faire quelque chose j'en
ai pas vu beaucoup vraiment j'en ai pas
vu beaucoup ressortir le doigt après
donc il ya un côté un peu excité je sais
pas si je dois dire excitant fascinant
et il ya un très bon exemple de sart qui
a été donné par l'exemple de la
convention citoyenne récente
c'est très intéressant de noter est que
quel que soit l'avis technique qu'on
puisse savoir sur leurs propositions
parce que dans les propositions les 150
qu'ils ont fait il y en a certaines que
je trouve très intéressante certaine que
je trouve un peu moins approprié
certaines me disent là je pense qu'il ya
un truc qui l'ont pas saisie mais peu
importe ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'ils ont dit alors qu'ils se
connaissaient pas au début que ces 150
personnes qui ne se connaissent pas au
début d'accord ils ont dit à partir de
maintenant ça va pas s'arrêter là on
fait une association et on est tous
dedans
donc pour moi c'est assez sale
enseignements majeurs de cette
convention c'est là c'est l'effet
d'attraction très très fort que possède
ce sujet une fois qu'on a commencé à
mettre le pied dans la piscine ça se
trouve c'est le truc qui me rend un peu
optimiste parce que je veux dit il ya un
élément déclencheur dans cette affaire
il ya eu une vertu à la pédagogie
même si le problème est désagréable à
entendre
au moins ça remet le monde en cohérence
alors j'ai compris a pas très longtemps
qu'à cohérence était aussi un processus
enfouis autre effet un accès revel qui
avaient beaucoup d'importance pour nous
saran le monde visible ça le rend
prévisible donc ça le rend prévisite ce
n'était pas sympa mais au moins ça le
rend de nouveau prévisible et donc on a
envie de s'inscrire dans quelque chose
qui permet où on comprend ce qui se
passe et d'agir sur quelque chose qu'on
se met à comprendre
voilà donc je pense que c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je le vois que
très peu de gens faire machine arrière
après avoir commencé à s'agiter dans
cette gadoue
merci beaucoup et j'avoue racks et c'est
un voyage très très important pour nous
de l'arrivée à mieux décoder ce qui se
passe il a bien expliqué et finalement
c'est de nous inquiéter
tu nous donne aussi quelques pistes
quand même de ce qu'on peut essayer de
faire et la question de katell était
tout à fait perdu 1 qu'est ce qu'on peut
finalement concrètement est ce que
chacun d'eux chaque citoyen peut faire
quelque chose et tu nous laisses pas
quand même totalement abandonnée mais
nous allons quand même quelques
suggestions
je remercie beaucoup et il nous donne
aussi des éclairages sont des questions
qu'on se pose tous l'hydrogène par
exemple le futur du nucléaire
le fait que les états unis et la chine
maintenant 10 convoi arrive on vend des
efforts est ce que tout ça va vraiment
améliorer le les générations futures
parce que c'est pour eux qu'on travaille
à court terme c'est trop tard maintenant
on peut pas faire grand chose mais pour
le long terme
ensemble on peut faire on doit faire des
choses sur l'adaptation c'est à dire que
comme le coup est parti il faut aussi
qu'on sentait qu'il n'y avait pas de
questions là dessus mais il faudrait
qu'on s'en occupe à leur merci beaucoup
merci merci aussi et katell d'avoir
accepté d'être avec nous ce soir et nous
aider pour de l'institut hausse et que
tu te diriges je peux rajouter juste un
petit mot à ce propos est de dire que au
delà de notre nom aux responsabilités en
tant que citoyen à l'insee a bien
entendu on a aussi une responsabilité
collective
lorsqu'on est un organisme d'éducation
et puis qu'on forme des gens qui vont
entrer dans le business et le rôle
justement de l'institut que je dirige i7
2 d'intégrer ce pas dans notre
curriculum dans la recherche et dans les
opérations de dès l'école donc il faut
aussi montrer que les organismes
mentionnés c'est un bon exemple d'une
énergie aussi les équipes techniques qui
sont derrière qu'on ne voit pas sur les
écrans mais qui sont avec notre travail
et pour préparer cette conférence et les
conférences culture myriam l'oci qui
travaillent
pour la préparation et puis tous les
auditeurs en ligne qui sont là c'est
qu'ils sont et ils ont été fidèles et
j'espère retrouver le 21 janvier pour la
conférence de paul eric heck
sur un autre sujet assez important aussi
et en tout cas jean marc bien merci pour
ce soir merci à vous et bonne
continuation